y en directo ahora vamos hasta Buenos
Aires con el periodista Ludovico Mori
para hablar de la jornada inaugural de
la Cumbre global de alcaldes c40 que
tuvo lugar allí en la capital Argentina
un encuentro que acoge a unos 100
mandatarios locales de Grandes urbes
como Bogotá Barcelona París o seúl
Ludovico Gracias por acompañarnos
cuéntenos Cómo se desarrolló la jornada
de hoy y de qué temas hablaron durante
el encuentro
Buenas noches Andrés Sí después de la
jornada preliminar de hacer hoy fue el
día de los alcaldes y al centro de la
agenda surgió una ambicioso proyecto
para la creación de 50 millones de
empleos verdes para empleos verdes
entiander empleos que sean relacionados
con la acción climática
tales como
empleos relacionados con
el desarrollo sostenible
y en la y también el cambio climático
Así que esto es el principal que se
discutió hoy lo ilustraron distintos
sindagos alcaldes de todas las ciudades
del mundo habló la alcaldesa de
París Ana Hidalgo la alcaldesa de Bogotá
Claudia López y
y junto a este tema se surgieron también
a otros puntos que son relacionado con
esto de
climáticas Ludovico hay un tema o un
término más bien que llama la atención y
es el de ciudades de 15 minutos del que
también se habló Precisamente en la
Cumbre de qué se trata
sí es un concepto que surge por otro
lado de la idea de un urbanista
colombiano que enseña la prestigiosa
Facultad de las hormonas de París y es
un concepto que fue adoptado por la
alcaldesa Ana Hidalgo en su programa
electoral del 2020 se trata de
un concepto que mira a la sostenibilidad
y a la proximidad los conceptos de
proximidad en las grandes metrópolis
en este sentido
habló y la alcaldesa Ana Hidalgo de
París en un panel junto a la alcaldesa
de Bogotá Claudia López y
ilustrado este concepto van a Claudia
López se refirió con respecto a Bogotá
por ejemplo como epicentro de ciudades
sostenible del concepto de Ciudad
sostenible a este proyecto de las
Manzanas del cuidado
Así que esta es uno de los de los
proyectos junto también a los grandes
puntos de la agenda que después serán
plasmados mañana en el documento final
del consenso de Buenos Aires que tienen
que ver también con
el financiamiento de la transición
tecnológica digamos que todos es estos
grandes proyectos y ambiciosos proyectos
de
sostenibilidad por parte por parte de la
de las grandes metrópolis no podrían
llevarse a cabo sin una financiación
directa por parte de las grandes
organismos multilaterales como el Banco
Mundial y en el caso de la región de
América Latina el banco interamericano
de desarrollo